I'm having way too much fun
stranger things season 4 is here with
another season of just that stranger
stranger stranger stranger things that's
four right
thing we're finding the most uh peculiar
is the title of this show the more we
see the more we wonder if the show was
titled for the bloopers and silly
moments on set stick around and see for
yourself we should be the one that
starts the blooper reel
number one you might think that an eight
hour makeup call would put actor Jamie
Campbell Bower in a Stern mood after all
that's almost a full day's work just to
get ready to begin filming and while the
makeup team did their best to reduce
this time transforming a good looking
person into the harrowing full body
visual of vecna takes a lot of
preparation and careful execution so it
would be reasonable to find the vecna
actor in the kind of mood that might not
have time for shenanigans on set but no
in this blooper moment even the
nightmare inducing bekna has a moment
for a laugh with fellow actor Millie
Bobby Brown so you're in on the tricks
too huvechna we should have known number
two everyone is in their place the set
is quiet the cameras are ready the
lights are set the production staff
settles into their places sound is
recording and then quietly the director
says roll cameras and action a few quiet
breaths and it's time open your eyes oh
there's a camera on me Millie where on
Earth or the upside down did you go
maybe she was planning her next
practical joke on a not yet suspecting
cast mate we might never know but we do
know this set was destined for a few
dozen more bloopers than this one number
three it often seems to be while some
might say this cast gathers to tell the
story set out in the script others might
say the real goal is to up the ante on
the onset Antics we think neither party
would be fully wrong or fully right is
stranger things actually a reality TV
show in Disguise is the top prize
getting to start the blooper reel if so
we can't wait for the season premiere
what do you think number four are we
even surprised stranger things has taken
us to some stranger places and shown us
some stranger characters but there are
perhaps none more strange ER than what
we've seen here dim flooring colored
lights a fog in the air is that a large
audition panel we wonder if this behind
the scenes moment is Gaiden Matarazzo
pitching a big dance number for their
next season after all stranger things
has taught us that anything could be
possible Right let us know what you
think
number five if stranger things really is
a game of jokes there must be a
championship right oh it's the
championship game too much
with record-breaking time of the 53
seconds five
53 minutes and five seconds there's
something around that this Duo might
just have a new high score high score
for what you ask well boobies boobies
boobies boobies boobies boobies boobies
boobies how many quarters did they have
to drop in the machine to get that far
and does this belong in the Guinness
Book of World Records
number six eleven probably has the
widest array of outfits in The Stranger
Things Series this behind the scenes
footage hints that after Millie Bobby
Brown gets to weigh in on the looks for
her character 11. with the help of a
small team of costumers on hand So Glam
so fab she even got to choose what to
wear for the special occasion of getting
arrested we're so envious
number seven on screen stranger things
might appear to be a scary dramatic
sci-fi but off screen it's a comedy of
its own Noah schnapp calls it the shit's
creek of Netflix and he's probably onto
something this ensemble cast has a
growing reputation of distracting each
other on set take Finn wolfhard and
Charlie Heaton for example
number eight it's not all fun and games
on set sometimes the tricks play
themselves like while filming this
intense action sequence after plenty of
rehearsal and what seemed like a solid
performance and take here's the punch
line no one was expecting Finn wolfhard
has the story and so we do everything I
get there and then the camera whips to
the door and a soldier is not there when
the latecomer fell to the ground the
rest of the actors didn't know how to
react a door gets kicked in and the
stunt guy's like
but the stunt performer had one more
surprise for the scene and then he got
up and he's like I think that went well
what do you think accidental timing or
was this stunt performer looking for
their time to shine number nine stranger
things actor Millie Bobby Brown started
a competition on set and challenged her
friend and fellow actor Noah schnapp
killing time in between takes saw these
two racing to gobble tapes of Fruit by
the Foot mmm tasty while Millie might
have said a new tape gobbling record
Noah chocked up a did not finish and
intimidated by Millie's performance the
other cast mates refused to compete you
know what they say winning is a mindset
we hear Millie's moving on to the World
Finals
number 10 you miss every shot you take
right well stranger things actor Ira
Amex can be seen here making gun sound
effects with his mouth we're not sure
how accurately these projectiles will
fly but hey Ira's living Some solid
advice here Boom for the moon and even
if you miss you'll land Among the Stars
number 11. cries of horror from offset
has the upside down come to real life or
is it stranger things actor gain
Matarazzo and his mother in his trailer
in this behind the scenes coverage
Gayton shows us one of the stranger
things about his offset quarters the
sliding door to his bathroom won't stay
closed hmm strange or should we say
stranger the real question remains is
this a practical joke by one of his
castmates we think that's likely how
about you number 12. Sadie Singh's
character had one of the most
interesting Journeys during season four
of stranger things one of her standout
scenes would have been the moment she
levitated at the cemetery this behind
the scenes moment shows just how much
rehearsal in preparation Sadie and the
team went through to bring this
uplifting performance to life number 13.
we think you'll all agree when we say
one of the most terrifying creatures to
come out of stranger things is the
demogorgon but in this behind the scenes
footage we are more likely to mistake
the movement for yet another practical
joke instead of a serious action scene
while the final product brings this
terrifying monster to life while some of
the characters look on in horror the
onset footage is more likely to bring us
laughter as we can't help but think of a
certain friendly plasticine character
play fighting with these stunt
performers ah the magic of Cinema number
14. are we strangers or are we dancers
when they're working together to deliver
one of our favorite Seasons to date they
are often Playing Tricks on one another
but when they're not playing tricks the
cast of stranger things can be found
dancing while it might seem an
unexpected place to find this many stars
getting their grooves on these behind
the scenes Clips showed that this set
has Rhythm number 15. so maybe it's not
all sci-fi and tricks on the set of
stranger things in a rare moment of
wholesome affirmations this blooper
footage finds actor Charlie Heaton
unveiling some of the deepest secrets in
his trade how to act seriously we're
inspired what a way to start your day
you got this man
just me and you in here
that's what acting is
serious acting can we get this as a
ringtone for our alarm clocks
number 16 a quesadilla a day keeps the
demogorgons at Bay pretty sure that's
how the saying goes this must be why
stranger things actor Sadie sink woke up
to find her fellow actors indulging in
their daily dose of cheesy tortilla
right put yourself in Sadie's chair
cozied up under a thin blanket for a
brief nap it's 5 30 in the morning and
you wake up to find and I open my eyes
and Caleb and Gayton are just sitting
across from me staring ahead eating a
full-size like a quesadilla stranger
things has brought us a terrifying and
fascinating on-screen story with plenty
of shenanigans tricks bloopers and
practical jokes from the behind the
scenes and season 4 was of course no
exception we can only imagine what kind
of laughs and show-stopping moments that
another season or even a spin-off would
bring which actor do you think played
the most tricks behind the scenes let us
know in the comments